I didn't think this was going to turn up
the way it did videos like this make me
Furious and not just because the TSA
totally dehumanizes Travelers the agency
gets billions a year and requested 10.4
billion in 2024 even though agents are
notorious for failing undercover weapons
tests they repeatedly violate sick or
disabled passengers like this
three-year-old in a cast this woman with
a medical device or this man in a
wheelchair blue shirts have even been
caught stealing during screenings agents
repeatedly mock the erosion of your
freedom it's not personal it's science
and the agency's new facial recog
technology is a major red flag for
privacy rights but this after 22 years
this is why the TSA needs to be
abolished in any other case this would
be considered sexual assault but when
the TSA does it it's become a condition
part of travel so whether you're a
vlogger or my mom going to Mexico you
shouldn't have to let the government
grope your genitals just to get on a
plane